most people know that if you try to spin  a boiled egg it'll spin nicely and when  you try to spin a raw egg it'll be a bit  more wobbly but there's a cool trick you  can do where if you spin a raw egg and  then you stop it the raw egg will start  spinning again what's going on why does  it keep spinning well it's because of  something pretty important to physics  which is called inertia inertia is the  property that all objects have which  keeps them doing what they're doing so  when you get the egg spinning the yolk  inside is spinning as well and if you  stop it from the outside if you stop the  shell the yolk keeps spinning inside so  it'll get the egg spinning again without  you having to touch it whereas with a  hard-boiled egg because the thing is  solid inside because the egg is solid as  soon as you stop the shell you stop the  whole egg and there is no more inertia  to keep the egg spinning